okay
let me get started i'll give you the
premise the premise is the issues are
not av related the issues are that my
laptop where i was up until 4am last
night writing this talk
did not boot at all and as a consequence
of that my notes that i spent quite a
bit of time putting together are not
available to you but i am still on the
hook to keep you entertained for 30
minutes so we're going to see what i can
live code off the top of my head on my
secondary device which has a really
terrible keyboard this is like the worst
keyboard in the world what i can do to
keep you entertained for 30 minutes
because that's what i promise you
actually promised you 45 minutes but at
least you can excuse me the 30 minutes
unfortunately it's not the talk that i
had presented to you probably that's
going to happen at a future event once i
can actually get that laptop to boot the
notes are stuck bear in mind this is
sometimes you know these kind of
byzantine errors i do a 90 minute
seminar every week and you never know
what kind of baroque or byzantine era
can occur in the middle of one of these
things that's why it's important to be
prepared whatever the case may be this
talk is titled how can i keep you
entertained for 30 minutes we're at pi
data london 2022 it's due sunday june 19
2022 i believe my name is james powell
if you like this talk i don't know
what's wrong with you but you can follow
me on twitter at don't use this code
and we do of course seminars every every
week we do corporate training as well so
if you're interested in what we have to
talk about feel free to sign up for that
this will also be a demonstration of how
well i can speak and teach
extemporaneously on a topic with zero
literally zero preparation on what is
honestly probably the worst keyboard you
have ever seen so here's what we're here
to talk about we are all some sort of
data focused or data scientist
and as a consequence of that we see that
there are tools that we may use every
single day tools like pandas or x-ray or
matplotlib or numpy and it's the case
that we may very quickly discover that
you know what we don't really need to
know that much about python in order to
use these tools in fact really what is
there to python but say function calls
right there's basically function calls
and variable names and then api calls
and so if we take a look at what's
available in something like pandas we
might say well pandas has just memorized
set access and rename and set index and
things like that with no coherence
behind it hopefully using this terrible
laptop with terrible keyboard i'll be
able to give a lightning talk in a
couple minutes to show you where that
coherence is but fundamentally the
programming language that's provided to
you python is not just function calls
and variables there's way more richness
to it i'll give you an example of that
and this is something that i'm surprised
never really comes up even though it is
such a useful tool if you think about
the dichotomy between say lazy and eager
computation
and you think about things which python
programmers tell you about all the time
but it goes in one ear and out the other
like hey aren't generators really cool
who cares well the reason that nobody
cares is generally the dichotomy between
lazy and eager computation is one
talking about the amount of time of two
different aspects of your code either
the amount of time of some incremental
operation
or the amount of time to decide whether
to do the entirety of that computation
when you talk about lazy computation
it's usually because the incremental
time to do one step tends to be
significantly greater than the time to
decide this is where generators come up
with but what you're more familiar with
as a data scientist is tools like numpy
and pandas which are strictly eager
computation tools in fact oftentimes
fully in memory tools everything is
right there you perform a computation
and it gets done immediately and the
reason why things like generators never
come up is because in a tool like that
the time to do an incremental
computation is significantly less than
the time to decide whether to do the
next computation for example in a numpy
and d array it is sometimes faster to
perform extra operations and simply
throw them away than to
make a choice so you will discover if
you have a numpy and d array
that using something like numpy.where or
even doing some sort of indexing like if
you have an array with some values and
you index like this and then you take
each value and you increment by one this
will actually often times be a margin
slower than if you just say well x is
equals
you know x is plus one on every single
element times a mass of
x is less than zero
plus
x is times the mass of x is greater than
zero that'll actually be faster doing
more work and this is a little bit
perplexing but this also tells us why it
is that for example data scientists do
not seem to care about lazy
computational mechanisms outside of say
when it reaches a certain level like the
desk level they don't care about the
simple tool right in front of them the
generator
if you think about it what is a
generator a generator is a way for you
to use an out-of-band encoding in order
to express the stages the steps the
portions of a computation so what you're
saying is this computation has multiple
parts associated with it if you really
think about it something like a function
can do multiple things in it you know if
you have some input data in this
function you can perform a bunch of
different computations you can say data
plus one data times two
data
uh maybe to the third power that that
times key is really hard to hit and
there's actually three things that
you're doing here but the interpreter
can't see that and you're not
delineating that in any fashion this is
like some sort of data like a string
which has commas in it where you're not
saying oh this is where this entity
exists this is where this ending exists
and these have these delimited there's
clearly three steps here but you're not
providing any information to the
interpreter to indicate that and with
the generator all you're really doing is
taking the same computation and you're
saying you know what i'm going to make
it clear
where each step begins and ends and
where each logical step begins and then
because obviously the interpreter can
already see where each byte code begins
it ends and obviously you know with
things like the global interpreter lock
it will lock to or lock the interpreter
to the execution of a single byte code
well
if you look at something like this this
is the same operation as above the same
computation the same three things are
being computed but we've split it up
into parts this is why this is such a
useful tool for lazy computation what
you're doing is taking a large
computation breaking it down into parts
and saying
this part this part and this part can be
run independently and in between you can
decide if you want to keep running
so
if it's the case that the time for the
incremental step
is much larger than the time for the
choice to keep going the time to decide
whether you want to take your generator
instance and ask it do i want the next
value
if that choice tends to be
sl faster than the choice of the
increment computation then that's what
you want to generate which means that
there's probably a lot of data science
code out there especially any sort of
library that really isn't written in an
appropriate way because if you think
about it this generalizes to any large
scale non-closed form operation where
the incremental computation is slow for
example a simulation think about a
simulation in a simulation you may take
some input data a numpy and array an
x-ray data array or for example a data
frame of some sort and what you're going
to do you can do some sequence of very
complex operations and if those complex
operations take more than about a
microsecond then the time to re-enter
the python interpreter is going to be
really negligible
if that operation takes a nanosecond
like it's a single integer add then the
time to re-enter the python interpreter
will be so high that you just want to do
this eagerly you'll do it all in memory
you'll just blast down those values and
you'll see that'll be the f the fastest
approach
but
in the case where you have a simulation
where each incremental step of that
simulation is expensive which is not
uncommon think about operations on a
very large matrix those are expensive
they may take time there may even be
operations that are multi-stage that
require going out to external data where
it may be the case that one step of the
simulation is a second long
well
this simulation should be modeled as a
generator the reason that you want to
model this generator is you can then
really release
a certain presumption that you have
about how you've modeled this think
about anytime you have some sort of
simulation when you have a simulation
you have to decide what the api for that
simulation is and you have to decide
between a lot of choices like do i run
the simulation for a certain number of
steps do i run this simulation until i
hit a certain threshold
do i run this simulation for a certain
amount of clock time
and you encode that in the api for the
simulation because you say well you know
what i don't want to run extra work i
don't do extra work i don't want to run
this for 10 seconds if i only need to
hit a certain threshold i only want to
run it for five seconds and you allow
the user to control that externally via
this api but this is the wrong thing to
do because the generator says i don't
care how long you want to run this
computation you decide how long you want
this computation what i'm going to do is
i'm going to delineate the steps of it
and after each step i'm going to ask you
do you want to keep going or not and
then externally to this with a much much
simplified api you control
how you want to run this computation via
mechanisms like iter tools islice
or itter tools take while or some custom
generator you can write yourself like
you could write one that is a very soft
time counter like this you know timed on
some generator here and you say this is
it takes the start i'm actually kind of
getting used to this keyboard
and then you say you know something like
4x in
g
and if you're if you over
if you go over your
benchmark time then you stop
otherwise you yield x well this is
something that for whatever reason i
think is a consequence of
a lot of data scientists they look at
the code they look at their apis that
they know they memorize the apis and
they forget that there's an entire
language behind an entire language for
modeling these things and they see
repetition in their code when they see
repetition in their code their only tool
is the very fundamental basic structures
they have
let me just write a function package
things up on function where they could
choose a much more appropriate tool for
example a generator subject to meeting
that criteria of the incremental time
for the computation being significantly
larger than the time to re-enter the
python loop to decide whether to keep
going and what happens when they do that
is instead of writing
one function or three functions with
this extremely complex api they write
one representation of the simulation
which presumes none of these modalities
at all thus allowing the end user of
this thing to
arbitrarily decide
how i want to start or stop this
computation including modalities which
you could not foresee for example run
this simulation for 1000 steps or until
it hits a threshold value or a brand new
one like until the incremental
improvement is under a certain threshold
value
think about it whenever you write a
function and you presume these kind of
modalities especially where computation
starts or stops you're making
assumptions about where an end user
wants to start and stop that computation
and you're almost certainly going to be
wrong because if you think these are the
only three ways you can do this you're
absolutely wrong somebody's going to say
look we don't want to keep running this
computation as long as there's no extra
benefit so that's another modal
parameter and the apis will sprawl and
sprawl and sprawl let me show you
another example of this
it is very very common when you take a
look at data scientist code that
there seems to be a high tolerance for
repetition and the only mechanism for
eliminating that repetition is the
function let me pause for a second and
ask you a question when do you write a
function no no let me ask you another
question when do you not write a
function this is something that i'm very
surprised that a lot of data scientists
don't really have a good sense of
because they have these habits of oh
anytime i have repetition i'll write a
function they never really revisit that
and say well hold on a second if i'm
making an affirmative choice to do
something then there should be some
corresponding decision making process
under which i should not do that when do
you not write a function when you see
repetition in your code when do you not
write a function have you ever
considered that well it's actually
fairly clear when that situation is if
you think about it the
desire to write a function is usually
the desire to eliminate an update
anomaly in other words if you have some
sequence of scripts some sequence of
knowledge and you see you know a
repeated operation fgh and then fgh over
and over and you say that's very
repetitive let me eliminate that
repetition let me write a function
well the question that you should really
be asking yourself is is that repetitive
intentionally or is that repetitive
coincidentally
why could it be repetitive intentionally
for example these represent the one true
canonical way to operate some process
for example if you're working at a
secure classified site there are certain
processes you must follow you must
always follow those processes and you
can see those processes replicated
throughout the code base you may want to
establish a single source of truth for
how to do these processes such that if a
change occurs to this process it occurs
in one place and that change is
reflected in all instantiations and all
manifestations of that but it could also
be the case that this is very
coincidental it just happens to be the
case at this one point in time that
these are the same and where you see
this a lot is with data loading
anytime you see
deep in a library somebody doing
something like this with open file name
as f and they process this file name
there's probably something that's going
to go wrong later namely whenever you
think about it anytime you interact with
the outside world your interaction with
the outside world is not constrained on
your time schedule in other words i'm
loading some data that you provide to me
you decide tomorrow i'm going to give
you a csv file instead of a json file
what am i going to do my code just broke
i'm going to now
postpone all the activities that i have
planned for the week i'm going to work
through the weekend to solve this
interaction with the outside world is
one of these very large sources of churn
because the outside world changes and
you have to respond to it and react to
it similarly where it changes you often
have this desire to introduce a modality
so for example somebody wrote this
function f in order to perhaps load some
data from this file maybe this is a
json.load
on this
and they decided to package up a little
bit more than that maybe they did some
processing on this data to get some
result and they said well you know what
i'll put this into a function because i
see these two lines of code or these
three lines of code occur throughout my
code base people open the file and maybe
they do some data cleaning on the data
and then they
then they do some processing on the data
and i don't want to have my data
scientists cutting and pasting this all
the time but what they don't really
think about is maybe it's the case that
just at this one singular point in time
those four lines of code are being
repeated and maybe it's the case that
those four lines of code should retain
the ability to verge over time for
example if one of these users wants to
eliminate outliers
then
you would think oh okay i
write a write another line in this
function and when the other user says no
no i didn't want to eliminate outliers i
want to include them then you say oh you
know what i add a modality here with or
outliers equals false and i add a flag
and i say if outliers
or if not outliers
then something like that
and what you can think is whenever you
in accidentally reify repetition every
time you write a function where you
shouldn't write a function the general
pattern that you'll see is you'll start
adding flags and modes because the end
use case the manifestations of this will
start to diverge over time one person
wants to remove outliers one person
wants the file to skip the first line
one person wants it to be a csv file one
person wants it to be a gzip csv file
and it adds flag and flag and flag and
flag and flag and as a consequence of
that
the code just falls out of control
there's no way to test this thing you're
churning this function all the time well
this is a consequence of you reaching
for that habit of writing a function
without really thinking is this
coincidental repetition or is this
intentional repetition is there an
update anomaly in play i used that term
at the very beginning of this portion of
this very ad hoc talk and the analogy
that i want to share with you is this
when you think about a database you
think about database normalization the
reason why we do database normalization
is to eliminate certain anomalies in
other words
when i update a field here that fact is
changed everywhere through the database
everybody has experiences themselves you
buy a flight you change your seat on the
website you check your boarding pass on
the mobile app the seat hasn't changed
you call them up and say well i just got
upgraded why why isn't my seat change
they say oh we have two databases it
hasn't flowed through yet and you say oh
that's very stupid you should have one
single source of truth that's what a
function is a one single source of truth
the purpose of it is the elimination of
these update anomalies and if it's the
case that those facts are allowed to
diverge then you're actually unifying
things in such a way that you'll then
cause sprawl to cause modalities later
ultimately the intentionality of writing
a function really should be focused on
that repetition ad hoc behavior is in
fact generally okay to do
it's okay because it preserves your
ability to continue to change and to
have these pieces of code change over
time independently of each other and
really think about if you had some sort
of data loading deep in a library that
you were providing to another analytical
user and you changed the way the data
loading worked
how do you test that doesn't blow up
your other users how do you test that
the consequences of this aren't going to
affect somebody all the way over here
but if you had that data loading that
interaction with the outside world at
the most superficial part of your code
maybe all the way at that if name equals
main block then you change it to one
place and nobody else is affected you
can tangibly and and
very very directly feel the distinctions
between these but we have this habit of
writing functions now the next thing
that i wanted to share with you
is maybe another bad habit that we have
and it's related to
uh do i want to talk about loading
functions i already talked about loading
functions oh
i'll talk about ad hoc behavior
one of the other things that i think we
sometimes don't
don't encourage our
data science colleagues to do enough of
is to think about python in terms of
certain patterns or certain conventions
certain habits that we see the standard
library move towards that we should
encounter in our own work one example
that i like to use is if you think about
the inter tools module you can think
about the other tools module in a very
very
uh
superficial fashion you can think it
gives you things like combinatorics like
the ability to create cartesian products
or combinations or permutations you can
think about it in terms of very
simplistic things like generalizations
of
concrete mechanisms for example i slice
is a generalization of slicing on
concrete data i slices i say my idea is
slicing but on non-concrete data
but when you think about these and you
think about these in terms of things
like zip and enumerate what you're
missing here when you look at the
superficial details is there's a general
pattern here and a pattern of iteration
helpers the idea that whenever you're
doing some sort of iteration especially
in python you're usually trying to
encode
some process that a human being probably
cares about in other words if you really
think about your data science code and
you think about where loops show up in
your data science code it's often the
case that loops don't show up at the
computational side for example you don't
loop over each element of the numpy and
drain manually to add one to them you
push that computation to the restricted
computation domain you push it deep into
the c or fortran layer in order to do
this efficiently because the only way
you're guaranteed to be able to do it
efficiently and so if you have some
let's see if i can get you some random
data numpy.random default rng
see i even took the effort of doing this
properly so here you go size
equals three by three
and if you wanted to do some computation
on this you'd say okay xs plus one you
wouldn't do the looping over each of the
elements but where you'd see some of
that looping is well actually at the
human level not at the machine level not
at the data level i want to represent
the idea that i'm doing three different
scenarios so my scenarios may look like
this scenario one
or scenario a i add 1
scenario b i add 2 and so forth and so
on you might even use a python
dictionary in order to model these and
you have some loop that says for the
name of the scenario and the
adjustment
you
do some sort of loop
oh that's really hard there we go
and you do something like this x's plus
so here you have your data out here
maybe
and then you kind of plus the adjustment
and so typically where you see these
kind of looping you're trying to express
some human intention go through each
scenario and do this and where you don't
see the looping is typically where you
want to express some computational
operation oh actually go through each
individualized element and add one to it
well when you think about this what are
these iteration helpers all about the
iteration helpers are usually about
surfacing modalities making it so that
the choices that you might make along
the way with the iteration are visible
to the end user in that for loop block
and so for example if you think about
things like enumerate the purpose of
enumerate is to tell you where where you
are in the iteration am i at the
beginning of the iteration at the end of
the iteration you may have seen in past
in some of these talks i've written some
of my own iteration helpers like from
intertools we can pull in i slice and t
and we can write our friendly ny's
helper and you know the track the the
talk is more or less going back on track
when i start writing nys because this
has come up many times before but you do
something like this i think you i slice
g from i to none
for i g
in enumerate t
gn
oh got one more here and then you know
you can even do things like writing ny's
longest which use a zip longest
and this allows you to write something
which i don't know that i'll be able to
write for you
which is last but i can show you first
and that's pretty easy here let's do
repeat and chain
and what you can see here is i'm writing
iteration helpers not for the purpose of
showing off what i'm able to write on a
terrible keyboard live in front of you
but instead for the purpose of showing
you that these are small little tools
that are quite helpful for exposing your
intentionality and for improving your
code and for convincing your colleagues
to improve their code beyond what
they're capable of doing so for example
you write an iteration helper like first
that takes some generator like this
and
it does something like
repeats say the value true end times
repeats
the value false forever
change those together and zips it with
some generator or some iterable to be
more precise and what you can think is
the purpose of this is to allow you to
write code like this for first
x in or for
is first
x
in first oh that's horrible
and it doesn't help that it's really
nervous when you do that when these
things are done
off top of your head something like this
you can actually identify what mode
you're in you can identify if you're the
first value in fact it turns out that
things like last are very easy right so
if i had the time i'd probably write
something like this for you where you
can do something like identify the first
element and the last element of an
iteration and remember you're not doing
this in order to support the underlying
computation you're doing this in order
to support
the
intentionality and the human
intentionality and the ability for you
to express at the ad hoc level at the
for loop level oh this is the first step
of the simulation i'm looking at this is
the last step of the simulation i'm
looking at these are all the other steps
of the simulation i'm looking at in
essence what we can see from this and i
think we're nearing the amount of time
that we had what can we see from this
we can see that number one it is very
very difficult to put together a
coherent talk with no notes live coding
with no plan ahead of what you were
going to talk about in 30 minutes number
two i hope i've succeeded at it but
number three a very important lesson
when you take a look at what python
provides you and you think about it as
oh it's so easy it doesn't have
controversies and covariance like java
oh it's so easy it doesn't have template
meta programming like c plus plus well
that doesn't mean that it's necessarily
a tool that you can use so superficially
so readily it means that this is a tool
that has a certain richness and a
certain set of approaches and tools that
if you're just trying to shrug your
shoulders and say oh i know the numpy
api know the pandas api what more is
there it's just a bunch of function
calls and keyword arguments you're
missing an enormous amount of what you
can do effectively in your code simple
mechanisms like generators should show
up more in our code they should show up
anytime we have some sort of simulation
or some sort of non-closed form
operation where the
incremental step is large enough that we
can actually pay the cost of going back
into python to decide where they keep
going mechanisms like functions are not
the habits that we just want to write
anytime we see repetition write a
function we should be thinking about
these things with a little more depth
because i know for certain you have some
colleague who started writing code in
python maybe a modeler maybe a scientist
of some sort and they learn functions
then everything is now in a function
with a million arguments and it falls
out of just you just lose your ability
to maintain this code because the
keyword arguments keeping it added on
and on and on and they never really
think to themselves why am i doing this
in the first place we should really be
thinking a little bit deeper about why
we choose to use even the most basic
tools we have and when we look at python
and we see things in the standard
library or if we see things in the
built-ins like
like enumerate or zip or we see things
like itter tools we should look a little
bit beyond the superficial details of
what they appear to offer to us and
really see what is the convention what
is the intentionality here what is the
goal here because largely it is the case
that these are tools that are provided
to help us write better code not better
code in the form of faster code but
better code in the form of code that
exposes our intentionality exposes the
choices that we may make that may later
on change that we want to be very
reactive to being able to change later
on
that makes it possible for us to write
code that
put some structuring around the core
computation now with that said i hope i
was able to entertain you i think we're
just at the time that we have
thank you everybody i'm james powell
hopefully i'll give the real talk